[Musique]
une visite officielle qui a tout l'air
de retrouvailles entre de vieux amis
c'est la première visite d'État de Joe
Baden depuis qu'il est président et la
Maison Blanche a mis le paquet pour le
président français le tapis rouge est
déroulé 21 coups de canon et la
Marseillaise a résonné en plein cœur de
Washington
les deux dirigeants veulent afficher un
front uni une alliance presque
indéfectible selon Joe Biden
la France est notre plus vieil alliée
dit-il face au retour de la guerre sur
le sol européen suite à l'agression
russe contre l'Ukraine et face aux
crises multiples qui frappent nos
nations et nos sociétés
il nous faut savoir
redevenir frère da une alliance qui
avait plutôt mal commencé il y a un an
la France avait rappelé son ambassadeur
de Washington après l'annulation par
l'Australie d'un gros contrat d'achat de
sous-marin français au profit des
Américains
autre tension commerciale Paris déplore
le protectionnisme américain au
détriment des entreprises européennes en
particulier les flèche une réduction
actes
sont des choix qui vont fragmenter
l'Occident aujourd'hui le ton était plus
conciliateur et donc la France n'est pas
venue ici demander en quelque sorte pour
son économie telle ou telle exception on
veut réussir ensemble pas l'un contre
l'autre ensemble aussi sur la question
ukrainienne
aujourd'hui les deux leaders sont unis
contre la Russie
Poutine est en train d'infliger un
terrible carnage à la population civile
en Ukraine dit-il
s'il y a une voix pour arrêter la guerre
Emmanuel Macron depuis le début du
conflit il a toujours maintenu une
communication avec Vladimir Poutine et
donc en particulier j'aurai une
discussion sur la question de la sûreté
et de la sécurité des centrales
nucléaires dans les zones contestées en
particulier cette deux aporida
les deux pays s'engagent donc à soutenir
l'Ukraine aussi longtemps qu'il le
faudra
Washington a l'intention de bien ménager
son allié européen
400 personnes ont été conviées pour le
dîner d'Etat dont le cinéaste français
Claude Lelouch Emmanuel Macron
s'envolera pour la Nouvelle-Orléans de
ma vendredi la première visite d'un
président français depuis 1976 il s'est
abonnée Yorki Radio-Canada Washington